I can talk to fish what can we do with
that that's cool maybe commander an army
of billions in the ocean uh yeah hi
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my Shazam post-credits scene video and
mid-credits scene if you have not seen
the movie careful for spoilers but we
will do a new round of the imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Sam comment
on the video starting with the
mid-credits scene it begins with mr.
mind coming to dr. Savannah's prison
who's being held in captivity he's been
scribbling magical runes all over the
walls trying to find a way to escape mr.
meyen starts laughing at him from the
window dr. sivana is confused he didn't
see him earlier in the movie when he was
inside his little jar inside the rock of
eternity so dr. sivana has no idea who
mr. mind is mr. mine says you humans
think there's only one way to get magic
there are many ways we will have such
fun
the seven realms are about to be ours if
you've been reading the recent Shazam
rebirth comics this may sound familiar
to you because he's referring to the
seven realms of magic also known as the
magic lands of the rebirth era comics is
a brand new concept that will be part of
the next Shazam movie in any potential
future sequels because is this really
big place like we talked about how the
movie is riffing on Goonies stranger
things in the it movie because there's a
little bit of horror element to it think
about the magic lands is sort of like a
bigger version of the upside down it's
several different dimensions and realms
within the multiverse
mr. mines real name is max of vermis
mind he's an alien Venusian worm species
who's bent on taking over all magic
within the movie universe but he has a
comic book history that goes way back to
the 1940s in the original Shazam comics
he's one of Shazam's oldest biggest
comic book villains he's got powers of
mind-control he's almost immune to
Shazam's magical lightning and his
extremely long lip he's capable of
living for hundreds and hundreds of
years so that's why he goes way way back
with the council of magic in the wizard
Shazam it's implied that when we first
see him captive in his little jar on the
rock of eternity when dr. sivana is a
child at the beginning of the film that
he was captured by the wizard Shazam a
long time ago and had just been biding
his time waiting for a chance to escape
which dr. sivana provides him with later
in the film when he returns and takes
the seven deadly sins
originally when mr. mine first debuted
he was part of a group called the
monster Society of evil I don't know if
they're gonna try and do that within the
Shazam movies they may have a reference
to that in the future sequel or maybe if
they do a trilogy they'll wait to the
third film to do some sort of villain
team-up with Black Adam the monster
Society of evil is also one of the very
first teams of super villains in the
comics but Black Adam has never been a
member of it before it's typically made
up of world war ii era villains because
that's sort of when those people debuted
but mr. mind originally debuted and
Captain Marvel Adventures number 22 in
1943 so you're talking World War 2 era
later in the 1980s after crisis on
Infinite Earths he did have a big team
up with dr. sivana but that time he was
trying to plan a full-blown invasion of
Earth so obviously the movie Shazam is
largely based on Jeff John's new 52
Shazam run in some of the rebirth stuff
Allah
magic lands that they tease at the end
of the film the mr. mind scenes that you
see during the movie are directly taken
from that new 52 run he shows up right
at the end of that after dr. sivana has
been defeated even though a lot of
different things happen Black Adam is a
big part of it the actual story got
changed quite a bit but mr. mine was
captive in a jar in the rock of eternity
at the end of that story Black Adam is
sort of subjugated dr. sivana so he went
off on his own
defeated the Shazam family teamed up in
a theme park to fight Black Adam then
later there's a post-credits scene where
mr. mine comes to dr. sivana and says
aha we still have much to do then they
had the big rebirth reboot in DC Comics
and they just picked up that story where
they left off with dr. sivana in rebirth
with mr. mine trying to conquer the
magic lands so you can actually read
that story as it's happening right now
before the Shazam sequel comes out and
you will have an idea for what they're
gonna do with the magic lands but the
magic lands are seven different realms
of reality where magic reigns supreme so
the rock of eternity is connected to all
different realities all planes of
existence via magic like the wizard says
at the beginning of the movie is the
source of the river that is magic
flowing into all different realms so
when the Shazam family is running
through the rock of eternity trying to
escape dr. sivana and they
start randomly opening doors to
different dimensions the sort of a
teaser for that just explaining that the
rock is connected to different
dimensions via portals but the only way
into the magic lands is via a special
train inside the rock of eternity
because the story of the magic lands is
still unfolding we've only gotten a
couple issues of that comics so far we
don't know everything about all seven
different realms but we do have a map
here that shows you where they are where
they're located
the first realm is called the earth
lands it represents our main reality in
the multiverse the other six realms of
the magic lands are located inside what
they call the sphere of the Gods within
the layer of the multiverse so you look
at Grant Morrison's map of the
multiverse here the sphere of the gods
as the name implies is where pretty much
every type of God within the DC universe
lives the new gods Darkseid the Greek
pantheon of the Wonder Woman movie
pretty much anybody that lives on that
level of reality the second realm is
called the fun Lance it's a big giant
theme park dimension populated entirely
by children and ruled over by someone
called King kid who claims he's the
secret seventh member of the Shazam
family so without giving away big
spoilers about the Shazam rebirth comic
book storyline that's actually happening
right now like I said you can read along
with it if you want to
they'll probably finish that story line
before Shazam too comes out in a couple
years so you have plenty time to catch
up on that before the sequel gets here
but if you look at the map here the
other five realms that we have not
traveled to yet in the comics or the
game lands the dark lands the monster
lands the wild lands in the woes endure
lands by the time we get that blackout a
movie that they keep talking about maybe
we'll know about cup of these other
realms that will talk about them because
it does sound like they're heading
towards a really big battle inside the
magic lands because it's such a huge
space with so much mythology that
there's no way that they're gonna get to
all these different realms in the Shazam
sequel if they really wanted to they
could do different Shazam sequels in
each one of these different realms but I
don't think they plan to do eight Shazam
movies back-to-back they'll probably
just combine a lot of these in one or
two movies
moving on to the post-credits scene this
is just sort of the funny moment between
Billy and Freddy talking about fish
powers Allah Aquaman which we actually
saw in an earlier trailer that clip that
I put at the beginning of this is from a
Chinese promo that they released a month
ago it's funny that they would put the
post-credits scene inside an actual
trailer that they
released to promote the movie but it's
just Freddie wearing his Jason Momoa
aqua man t-shirt and Billy after the
events of the special lunch date with
Superman and the rest of the Shazam
family at the end of the film continuing
to test Billy for more different kinds
of powers like the ones that the other
members of the Justice League have
that's sort of their template for how
they test him for powers earlier in the
movie can he fly does he have heat
vision like Superman SuperSpeed like
Superman in the flash Billy looks at
their goldfish and says I can't talk to
fish that's a stupid power what kind of
cool things could you possibly do with
that and superhero fanboy Freddy tries
to explain Aquaman's powers to him I
don't know you know summoning an army of
fish to fight for you you know tugging
on the shirt Billy suddenly remembers
Aquaman exists oh yeah that is kind of
cool there is no black atom post-credit
scene even though they are currently
still supposed to be making that solo
movie with Dwayne Johnson the rock it
might wind up coming out sometime before
Shazam - which will affectionately call
Shazam - into the magic lands he does
show up about 30 minutes into the movie
when the wizard is explaining the
history of the council magic in the
seven deadly sins - Billy they changed
black Adams backstory just a little bit
from the new 52 Shazam comics but in the
movie version of events Black Adam
released the seven deadly sins on
mankind as revenge for the death of his
wife then the seven deadly sins went on
to kill the other members of the Council
of magic and that's how they died in the
comics it was Black Adam himself that
killed all the other members so we can
speculate on what parts of that that
they would include in a Black Adam solo
movie but the rumor right now is that
the story of that movie will be set
during more modern times maybe even
present-day involving some members of
the Justice Society maybe also based a
little bit on the story of black out in
the Dark Age there's still a lot of
speculation about what's going on with
that because they haven't said anything
recently but the rock is still under
contract to be the Black Adam of the DC
Universe but obviously a lot of creative
has changed behind the scenes in the
Shazam movie seems like it's gonna blow
up big time so if they still decide to
do a solo Black Adam movie next maybe a
small Shazam cameo somewhere in that
teasing a future crossover sequel where
they eventually fight each other but if
they wind up deciding to just skip a
Black Adam solo movie and put Black Adam
in the Shazam sequel early speculation
maybe he just pretends
to ally himself with dr. sivana and mr.
mind as they try to conquer the magic
lands and secretly double-crosses them
becoming the big bad trying to take all
the power of the magic lands for himself
so either way whether or not Black Adam
is in Shazam - you have Billy Batson in
the Shazam family teaming up again to
stop mr. mind dr. sivana and protect all
magic in all of realities because that's
actually one of Billy's jobs now as the
successor to the wizard Shazam become
the guardian of all magic as he is meant
to be the guardian of the rock of
eternity the source of all magic so if
you haven't seen the movie and you just
watch this video because you want to
find out what's going on at the end of
the film be sure to go see it is
actually really good I think it's going
to be a big franchise for DC because of
the way they developed a Shazam family
the different members they could just do
a self-contained Shazam universe but
obviously he has already met the Justice
League because Superman comes to eat
lunch with Freddy Freeman
regardless of what happens with Superman
and the other members of the Justice
League in future movies we know that
Wonder Woman is going to be around
Aquaman is going to continue to be a big
thing so there'll be some of them that
are still around regardless of when that
next Justice League team up movie
happens you'll probably continue to see
funny references and cameos from other
Justice League members in Shazam sequels
I'll be posting a whole bunch more
Shazam videos this weekend my full
review and Easter Egg video there were
all kinds of Easter eggs and references
so I named a giveaway winner when I post
my next video while you wait for
everything you can click here to
re-watch that Joker movie trailer
explained the continuity and how that
fits into the other DC movies and you
can click here for that brand-new
Avengers endgame footage thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight